yesterday
it spread like wildfire all across
twitter that a crypto punk was sold for
more than 500 million dollars people
were going absolutely bananas in terms
of trying to figure out what the hell
was going on we've got a picture of the
actual nft you could see that the bot
accounts that track the price they
started to just push all over the
internet punk 9998 was bought for 124
457 eath or about 532 million dollars
bam green eyed white-haired 500 million
crypto punk crazy right
well
hold on a second it wasn't actually what
you think it was
here is the type of manipulation that
occurs in some of these markets the punk
was put on sale by contract a
contract b took out a massive flash loan
what that means is they quickly borrowed
money 500 plus million dollars and they
used that loan money to go ahead and buy
the punk from contract a at that point
contract a received the eth
and contract b received the punk so they
swapped but then as soon as contract a
actually got the eth
they turned around and sent it all back
to contract b
and contract b then paid off the loan
the way to think about this is let's say
that i had one
contractor wallet and then i had a
second the first one i have this punk
that is sitting in it the second one i
take out a loan for 500 million dollars
i pay my first uh wallet for the punk
they send me the punk then that first
wallet pays me the money right back
without me giving back the punk i take
that money and i pay back the loan
happens in an instant and it looks like
a crypto punk was sold for 500 plus
million dollars but not so fast
this was probably the same exact person
or group and all they were doing is they
were using a flash loan to actually get
a transaction with a very high price
point so then people would talk about
the fact that a crypto punk went for 500
million dollars so you always got to be
careful because here this is the beauty
of on-chain metrics this is the beauty
of having a public ledger here is the
exact point where we can see it you can
literally go into like an ether scan or
a blockchain explorer and you can see
exactly what happened so part of the
beauty of this entire
system this entire open public ledger so
you can see it all and so
robert miller here
this wasn't a real sale this wasn't an
exploit either no one made money they
probably did this to generate a bunch of
buzz about it on twitter and troll a bit
so nothing wrong with it nothing illegal
about it
but what you can see is that it worked
in terms of generating the conversation
it went all the way up to us even
talking about it but because there's a
public ledger we are always able to see
it so the crypto punk did not actually
sell for 532 million dollars now some of
them have in the past sold for millions
of dollars i don't know maybe they will
continue to increase in price maybe they
won't lots of people seem to like them
there's literally everyone from jay-z to
others that have them as their profile
pictures uh and so it's very obvious
that there is a culture that is
coalescing around this they find this
valuable they find it interesting
but one did not sell for 500 million
dollars this is the great
500 million dollar sale that never
actually happened what did you guys
think when you saw 500 million dollars
for crypto punk did you think that that
was absurd or were you like there's no
way that's real to be honest i really
did figure that there was something
wrong because none of them have sold for
even close to that right the highest nft
sale ever was people and it was like 60
or 70 million dollars right so it's it's
much much much larger than the largest
ever uh and no crypto punk had even sold
close to that and i don't even believe
it was like one of the rarest ones so uh
immediately i think some people said hey
that's crazy some people said there's
got to be something wrong uh but the
other thing too is like i don't think
they were trying to trick anyone they
used the same wallet they could have
done a bunch of other things to try to
manipulate it or trick people into
thinking that something else was going
on i think they were just trolling and
they were saying hey look how you know
easy i can do something like this and
create a conversation around it and i
don't know if that's good right uh it
obviously drummed up a bunch of interest
and people were talking about it and uh
interested in that crypto punk
specifically this person owns a bunch of
them so maybe there's something around
that but at the end of the day the thing
that a lot of people forget is like this
stuff manipulation happens in every
market
specifically the traditional art market
also right so i don't own a crypto punk
i don't own anything like that i don't
uh have any skin in the game when it
comes to seeing the price appreciate but
i think it's important to to point out
your your uh point earlier which was
like the metrics and the on chain stuff
and just looking at these transaction
history tell us the story right and
users were within minutes like with
literally within 60 seconds to 120
seconds people were putting out tweets
saying it's fake this is what happened
they use the flash loan etc so it's very
easy to tell kind of what's going on in
this situation when you see the
manipulation between different wallets
so if it's someone trying to drum up
interest that's one thing if they're
trying to increase the price of it
that's another thing if they're trying
to trick someone that's another right
but i think they were just trolling uh
having some fun around and trying to
drop the conversation i don't think
anything was illegal done
and i think at the end of the day it's
probably much much much to do about
nothing john i don't know why they did
this taxes anything um
look technically it did sell it did sell
for 540 million just to the same guy who
who sold it bought it right um so i
don't know
on that point i believe it'll be
interesting to see because i believe uh
larval labs took the transaction off of
off of their record and said that didn't
count and then one of the other services
left it on and there was some kind of
dispute around whether they were going
to count it or not i mean let's be real
shouldn't count i don't i don't believe
his account but in the books technically
it did sell it just sold to the same
person who
the same person bought it who sold it
right i don't know how how christies
does there does their auctions or
anything like that but uh yeah i mean
it's interesting 500 what 530 million
dollars for an nft would be absolutely
mind-blowing though people sold for
around 70 million dollars i don't see
any nfts going for 540 million at least
not now um i'd be shocked if you started
seeing nfts go for hundreds of millions
of dollars um there's rare art that
doesn't even go and appreciate like that
so uh we'll see i mean there's few
people in the world that could afford
five more if you got a flashlight you
can afford whatever you want of course
of course but from like what's the
percentage uh what's the interest on
those flash loans i don't know but i'm
sure that they didn't lose that much
money if they were willing to do it if
they were one second 500 million dollars
it's like they saved me 500 million i'll
pay you back in 12 seconds yeah but the
idea that this stuff doesn't happen
maybe not to this degree but in the
traditional art world there's a joke
also right there's people there's plenty
of people manipulating the price like uh
banksy's thing for example when the one
that's shredded yeah there's like rumors
going all over the place that he
basically bought it knew that if he
shredded it would increase in value and
then when it sold it lately
that crypto punk just doubled in value
you think oh easy
easy because think about it what other
green eyed white-haired one do you think
about remember or whatever and now it's
part of the story well one time
i mean imagine you see that and then
every time you see that headline of hey
it's sold whatever you don't see fake
nft sold like a lot of places were
posting it like it was real like it was
just a traditional sale that happened in
the nft market and i bet people walk
away with that thinking of oh hey
remember that nft that sold for 500
million dollars people like oh you don't
remember that being fake and i was like
oh no like i didn't see that and talk
about it or whatever so just it brings
buzz into the nft market it's all
storytelling right so like the the the
only reason why i question if it doubled
is because the most expensive crypto
punk right now or ever was like 10
million dollars i forget the exact
number but around that range right so i
don't know how much this one was worth
before but is it going to be the highest
ever now i don't know the there was you
know reports that it's not even close to
the rarest one so i don't know
it is now the rarest maybe it's the only
one that ever was sold for 500 million
someone else someone else could just go
do the same thing now and and make that
not true i guess but uh oh you got to be
able to get a flashlight for 500 million
dollars
this guy seemed like he didn't do too
hard with the time doing it
i got to look into these flash loans no
i'm just curious
i don't need one but like i'm curious
what collateral they do what interest
rate it is it's an interesting one good
you can do it i mean it would be
interesting to see like obviously
there's an interest portion to it if
you're paying it back within seconds
then you know there's something to talk
about there but also the fees on a
transaction like that that's a cool
thing i imagine weren't you know pennies
so it's
if they own seven or eight of them then
they could obviously probably afford it
but if you know flash loans hit my dms
we'll have a conversation about it